Grand Theft Auto 5 already got into the  Valentine's Day spirit with the be my  Valentine update for GTA online but  Rockstar has even more love to share the  new adversary mode til death do us part  is live as of today Friday February 12th  Rockstar is calling the new mode the  ultimate quadruple date it's essentially  a free-for-all  with two person teams or couples stick  by your partner's side and you'll  regenerate each other's health but if  you die your partner ends at all and  vice versa  it's a little gruesome but it makes for  an interesting competition as mentioned  this new mode is part of the larger be  my valentine update if you're itching  for new costumes and cars those are  available to Rockstar has plenty of  discounts and bonuses available in-game  if you log in before February 18th and  if you want to keep up with all the GTA  news make a date with GameSpot we're  pretty much the Casanova video games